Andrew Whitworth the Rams offensive
tackle he donated his game check about
$60,000 after taxes to a fund
established to help the victims of the
shootings last week at the borderline
Bar and Grill in Thousand Oaks
California yep
tack on that with the fires here forced
to evacuate and certainly been a trying
time for a lot of people not only Andrew
who's kind enough to join us how are you
Andrew I'm doing good and I appreciate
it yeah man it's been a trying time for
our community and you know just really
been impressed with really how
everyone's kind of pulled together to
try to help each other out with this
thing obviously starting with the
shootings and then going into the fires
and just the job the first responders
have done through all of it it's been
amazing
explain to the audience what it was like
when you woke up and you knew that there
was there was trouble in the
neighborhood as far as the smoke and the
fires oh yeah I mean late Thursday night
about 3:00 in the morning about 2:30
3:00 in the morning just woke up and
could smell like it didn't it didn't
sound right I didn't smell right and
something's going on and walked outside
and could see ash and stuff in the air
and so you know next thing you know
phone starts buzzing and he started
getting alerts that you need to evacuate
and you know it went from being
voluntary to mandatory pretty fast
so for us and my household it turns into
loading up little kids and getting
everybody together making sure we got
sleeping toys and everything else so it
was quite a quite a night that's for
sure ended up getting in a hotel by
about 4:00 in the morning and getting
the babies down about 5:00 so caught it
quite an interesting night that's for
sure
did you know what is your health housing
tank yeah we've actually I think today
are getting they said they're going to
lift the mandatory evac today so they'll
get to go back to the house and so they
hadn't been there since Thursday so
obviously those kids getting a little
restless with that but yes it's good
that we get to go back and it seems like
our neighborhood you know came out
pretty good you know other than just
some simple smoke stuff nothing nothing
bad no no homes were burnt in our actual
neighborhood but you're grateful for
that the man just crazy to see
everything that went on around us what
prompted you
doneita game check
honestly that game you know from seeing
the shootings the the morning before and
you know just honestly sitting there
thinking what can you do in a time like
that I think everyone has to find you
know whatever it is for them that they
feel like they can try to do something
to put their arms around or love on
their community and so my wife and
household kind of went out we're in the
community that day giving blood and just
kind of being around individuals and
things and I was sitting at work
thinking man how can I possibly do
something that could kind of just in
some way let people know that I'm in
this with them and I want to help them
in any way I can and so that came pretty
seamlessly I texted my wife and told her
I wanted to do it she was all for it you
know I just think it's a it's a gesture
to let people know that you're there
with them that you know this is a part
of my community as well we all share it
and and sometimes you know in our
situations just doing something whatever
it is for each person is the best thing
you can do and not worrying about what
it is exactly you guys relocate to
Colorado Springs this week to prepare
for the altitude yeah yeah we we just
got in last night and so we're uh you
know getting settled here and getting
great rain in the altitude and get a
little used to everything so you know
hopefully uh you know works out in our
favor
have you done it before like can you
feel the difference basketball players
talk about that you know when they're in
my life I stood and I then I have a home
up here in the mountains actually that I
stay at the offseasons that's where I
train and I love it I think it's amazing
and it makes a crazy difference I mean
for me I spend the six weeks break after
OTAs and mini camp until training camp
in the mountains and train and when I
show up the training campus it's just
unreal amount of shape and just how good
you feel body was coming down from that
altitude so I really do believe in it
and I think it's something that that
helps a ton when you have to play at
elevation have you blocked for a running
back quite like Todd Gurley I would say
so that's pretty special you know but
you know what there
it's one of those things that I think I
feel like I keep saying it's about Jared
and over and over but it's just the
truth Jared and Todd both share this
they they're extremely talented young
guys that are just as talented at being
people I mean they are they are they are
great with their teammates they're great
with people on a general basis just to
talk to and their hearts and what they
want to do and the positive effect they
want to have on people and it just makes
it so easy to root for them because not
only how talented a guy like Todd is but
how much it means to him for you know
you to understand that he cares about
you and he wants everyone to do well and
what's the team to do well before
anything else I mean it just makes it so
easy to work with somebody who's that
talented and that special who also has
that kind of heart what did you think of
golf now tweeting out to Halle Berry
with this whole you know audible here is
he I think he's kind of over his skis a
little bit here and he yeah but you know
what you know he loved it I mean that's
Jared's a great kid and I think the
larious I mean that's hey hey he'll be
the most excited guy in America if she
tweets him back no I know that you know
I can't imagine if he times he's
refreshed his phone over the last four
days just just wait but you got to
invite her to a game you have to I mean
you know you know what giver Floyd
Mayweather seats there Andrew let her be
in the end zone there I'm not touching
that one day a well done Congrats on the
season and obviously the donation that
you did you and your family hope
hopefully it's good getting back home
and good luck against Kansas City thank
you Andrew Whitworth for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
you